well Harry force is joining us live now
from Keith I understand that Vladimir
zielinski has been talking to the
Reconstruction uh conference that's been
going on do we know what he's been
saying
yes he's been speaking uh via video link
in now pretty familiar and pretty blunt
terms about the uh The Plight being
faced by his country and the need for
the International Community as far as
he's concerned to do more he said that
of the immediate fast 17 billion dollar
fund uh required for reconstruction this
year and next uh he said they're not
Ascent of that had yet come through he
talked about the massive hole in
Ukraine's government finance's 38
billion dollars he said we know that the
the economy here has taken a hit in
terms of some 30 percent of GDP uh being
sliced off the economy by Russia's
Invasion and the the damage and
destruction that is eventuated from it
the the flight of people from the
country and the impact of course on
industry here and when it comes to the
Relentless attacks that have been coming
in the last couple of weeks on Ukraine's
energy infrastructure again and talking
about 33 percent of these vital energy
infrastructure nodes are being damaged
or destroyed in the course of that and
we also heard on Monday from his prime
minister Ukraine's prime minister saying
that in total uh 750 billion dollars
would be required in terms of trying to
rebuild Ukraine that's a number that
could of course inflate still further
the longer this war goes on and there
will be difficult choices to be made in
terms of exactly how to do that where to
spend that money whether it's just in
reconstructing what was destroyed or
coming up with more modern ways of doing
industry and business in this country
potentially a longer term and more
difficult process than just putting back
together what's been taken apart yeah
Harry we're also hearing that the un's
nuclear Watchdog is going to be sending
inspectors to Ukraine and that's because
Russia has been accusing Ukraine of
planning to use what's known as a dirty
bomb that's explosive laced with nuclear
material what more do we know about what
this me this visit is going to entail
well we know that it's going to happen
in the next few days according to the
head of the iaea it's something that the
ukrainians themselves are calling for
they have been utterly denying uh saying
that these claims are absurd and
dangerous and that they have no such
plans to concoct some kind of a dirty
bomb in Ukraine and blame it on Russia
that's the accusation that's coming from
the Russian side and so yes they've
invited these inspectors in uh the the
Russians are saying that there are two
nuclear institutions within Ukraine that
have been given the task of coming up
with this bomb and that it's in its
final stages the iaea is saying that
they inspected one of these two places
just a month ago and found nothing
untoward going on and that they are
going to send in inspectors into both of
them I spoke to a senior defense analyst
uh just uh yesterday evening about the
situation a senior member of the
National Institute first strategic
studies security studies rather and he
was saying that there is the potential
for or potentially Russia to do
something like this by using spent fuel
from the zaparesia nuclear power plant
which it controls but there are iea
staff there as well he said that this
was more about rhetoric and trying to
show that Russia was unbowed and willing
to escalate further that despite the
recent defeats on the battlefield it was
willing to carry on fighting Harry thank
you very much indeed Harry Fawcett
talking to us from Keith